okay look I just have one question
seriously who threw the rock in the
opening because because I mean like the
Angels wouldn't have thrown that rock
would they why they would have no reason
but who the heck else would be there to
throw that I don't know hey everybody
overdue Doctor Who review time and it's
time for that most iconic of episodes
but I think but before we get into it
this episode is sponsored by the podcast
radio versus the Martians it is a
fantastic podcast I'd listen to it even
before they started sponsoring some of
my videos and because it's a podcast you
don't have to spend money on it give it
a listen you've you know you've got time
your life at work you've got to drive on
get what you're working out something
give a listen to Mike Gillis and Casey
Doran because they are awesome they're
funny they have smart guests they talk
about cool nerdy stuff kind of like what
I talked about but you know you don't
have to see their faces whereas you're
kind of stuck with mine but they're
awesome stuff radio versus the Martians
where universes the Martians calm and of
course wherever you happen to get your
podcast I'm getting good at this so here
we go folks
blink this has always been one of those
really super highly rated episodes and
yeah there's a good reason for that I
think this is probably Moffitt's best
timey wimey episode certainly in terms
of making use of the mechanics of time
travel to tell a story in a different
way this is the tightest that certainly
Moffat ever explored it and I would say
like maybe with the exception of some
Big Finish to probably the tightest
exploration of that element of Doctor
Who that my
exist it's really really well pulled
together and it's also the sort of the
quintessential dr. light episode he's
barely in this yet his presence is felt
throughout and it still feels like
Doctor Who from top to bottom even
without him and it also helps that we
have really great cast because we've got
Sally and Larry now Sally tends to get
all the emphases so let me take a little
time to talk about Larry
um Larry's the kind of person I'd
certainly was at at some point in time
that's sort of oh you know this this
thing the ski Commedia we're all gonna
talk about it online and I go god I
still kind of do that don't I oh I
haven't changed in any case I kind of
like him he's a really sweet he's really
endearing but then you know Sally Sally
is a character who could have been
really pretentious and potentially very
grating but you know they got a
fantastic actress to play or so hey that
works out really really well it's
actually a really great cast all over
the other supporting characters as well
are quite good even sound like Sally's
friend who vanishes in the front end of
the thing she's great Billy Shipton both
old and young version and I really I
kind of love the bit of trivia that the
guy who played young Billy Shipton had
to rerecord all his dialogue and loop it
over his original recording because the
guy that got to be old Billy Shipton
couldn't you know he either couldn't or
didn't I can't remember if it was they
didn't think to ask him to or he just
couldn't mask his accent but the actor
who played Billy should then didn't play
and with an accent so he had to reel up
all of his dialogue with the accent to
match the old version I just kind of
liked that as a thing but also like this
a wonderful sense of sadness - Oh Billy
Shipton he's got that one line look at
my hands there old man's hands how did
that happen
and of course Sally herself also has
that sort of sense of that appreciation
of
well I mean she says that herself sad is
happy for deep people which like as I
said in the hands of the lesser actress
could have come across as really
stupidly self-indulgent ly insufferable
kind of line but know it it works
she's just able to give it that slight
knowing smirk behind it and and is able
to make it endearing and not infuriating
so she's a really terrific character but
let's mm-hmm
let's talk about the weeping angels now
I'll get my chance later on to talk
about the times when the weeping angels
recur again and some people will say
that you know they never should have
been brought back I'm not quite gonna go
that far because I do think we did get
some good stuff out of their returns not
across the board but there's some really
good moments that came out of there
being reused what I will say those they
were never gonna be this scary again
because what makes them so scary is you
don't know what's going on you're just
like that's statue moved and I don't
know why and I don't like it so and
that's not like they suddenly become
unscary in the course of this episode
you know when you find out what their
deal is but when they show up again
later you immediately know how they work
and while they've tweets that a little
bit you know in various stories you know
the basic principle of just don't blink
and and they and they can't get you so
that sort of initial oh my god what is
going on how do we stop it how do we
deal with it how we run from it even is
gone and that's kind of the inherent
problem of anytime you bring back a
legitimately scary monster is we've seen
how it operates so we can't catch us
off-guard Ali at the very least not to
the same extent if it can do it at all I
mean that's why they should never bring
back say the midnight entity that like
it would be the worst idea ever
um that's it I'll get my chance to talk
about the the weeping angels down the
line in terms of some things about
bringing the back that that did work but
you know for the most part this is just
a stellar tape you for monsters
it is a cool really cool concept and I
surprisingly I like the explanation
because sometimes dr. who will explain a
cool thing that like first of all
doesn't really need explanation but the
way that they'll explain it makes me
kinda go like I kind of had that
reaction to the carrionites in
Shakespeare code but here like they pick
just the right jargon I feel like their
quantum log they feed off potential
energy they're there I think even says
their abstract life forms like that like
this is just this is nonsense but it's
like perfectly worded nonsense and so
that that's just terrific
and I can't I cannot even begin to
imagine trying to chart out that
conversation with the DVD extra that
Sally has because you need to realize
that conversation the doctors end of it
a chunk of it has to play double duty
and play just as well - a completely
different set of responses that Sally
gives when she first sees the thing and
they still have to work and make just as
much sense for the actual responses she
gives later like as somebody with
writing ambitions who's you know who's
written fiction and then things of that
nature like the idea of trying to just
make that work and just like chart that
out and have that have that flow hmm
that's like that's that's just
technically narrative Lee really
impressive aside from just being cool
Martha doesn't get a ton to do in this
but you know I'm not sure there was a
lot she could do you know it's already a
doctor light episode but because so much
revolves around the TARDIS and the
angels looking for it and we get you
know a little bit more of the doctor
interacting he has a presence around it
whereas Martha basically just gets the
occasional remind
that she exists and while you know that
I I have complained and will probably
continue to complain about the series's
treatment of Martha as a character this
is a case where I'm like I'm not really
sure there was a way around that so
that's just kind of what happens um you
know she does have her nice little bits
of moments of obsess ribbing the doctor
for the fact that she got a job and now
she's supporting him which was kind of
cool and funny and actually since I
mentioned funny there's a surprising
amount of humor in this oftentimes scary
and funny go together really well
because humor is a great way to defuse
that because like building fear you know
when you when you do properly scare and
not jump scare but like properly scary
the fear builds and you need to release
that tension somehow otherwise you just
tense the whole time and you can only be
tense for so long before it becomes
unpleasant like just as a way to be and
attain to your viewing so if you're not
gonna relieve the tension with a scare
relieving it with a laugh that'll get
the job done as well and there's a
surprising amount of humor in this it's
it's quite a funny episode at times even
in situations where things get quite
dire and I and I so I think that's
another thing that this is just really
astoundingly well-balanced and I wish I
had like something newer profound to say
about this like to the point that I
almost was like dude should I like try
and come up with a contrary and opinion
on this just because everyone's talked
everyone knows this is a great episode
anyone who's ever talked about this
episode talked about what a great
episode it is but the thing is like in
my heart of hearts I've got really
nothing to say aside from the fact that
this is a really great episode so I
think we will wrap things up on that
particular note folks so I know you've
seen blank what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch of things to do
buttons links linked to radio versus the
Martians link to my patreon because I
appreciate the help quite a bit
other links besides to like stuff that
I've written or social media or whatever
go take a look at them click on things
consider you know doing the things that
clicking on those takes you to there's
merge there's other stuff or you know
don't click on any of it if you don't
really want to because at the end of the
day folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]